[Music]
and for Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber
they just want to feel normal
a source tells ET the couple is going
strong and settling into a normal
routine together despite Selena's mom
Mandy's disapproval the source explained
quote Selena is an adult and she's going
to make decisions for herself she values
her mother's opinion but not over her
own and Selena's opinion is that Justin
is a changed man the source said Mandy's
opinion of Justin is based on how she
remembers him from the past but the
source added quote a lot has happened
since then and Selena knows he's changed
and is in a better place and so is she
we've seen plenty of public appearances
from Jelena over the years at glitzy
Hollywood events but the source tells ET
this time they're trying to be less
high-profile since they rekindled their
romance in October they've been spotted
riding bikes attending church and
working out together ET spoke to Selena
in November she opened up about how
fulfilled she feels right now I like to
choose to live my life in a way where I
want to be wait free and I know that's
impossible to do because I have a
million on me right now but I and
everybody does but I think it is
important to kind of go through your
life the way you run and I like to come
at things with my best that's all I know
how to do is just give my best
[Music]
you